we're making your strawberry lemon ham
pies from maggie's sweet shop by
magnolia at the silos so um all right we
baked the pies they're looking gorgeous
yes grab a spoon and you can get this
little
offset spatula and if you want to get a
spoon um in your in your drawer
this is the lemon glaze and it's
basically just powdered sugar some
butter i really like that yes that size
is good too lemon zest
so i love again these are so organic
they're they're handmade so the idea of
it not being this perfect like icing or
frosting
i like that it kind of pours off the
edges so if you want you can just you
know again this is as much as you want
but this is just powdered sugar fresh
squeezed lemon juice some lemon zest
zest makes all the difference it really
does something about a fresh squeezed
lemon and then you can just kind of move
it around do whatever you want
it's like art class you know
if you were to take a girl's trip like
you're with you know i'm craving a girls
trip i like you're planning
to go somewhere and i don't know yet i'm
like trying to decide is it beach is it
big city is it
middle of nowhere i'm going to vegas
with michael okay that sounds really
cool they were like where are we going
and you know i literally go
vegan we're going to
i love that you ready yes
okay
now cheers cheers my dear
oh hold on
oh that is flaky flaky flaky
thank god for that little egg and all
that butter oh my god this is insane
like a girl's trip is like where can i
just go eat
all the things okay that's probably what
i'm wanting in april um i'm going to go
eat all the things and then just sit in
the hotel bed and watch tv
these are so incredible do they remind
you of your childhood or no way you you
see what i'm saying is there something
nostalgic about a craft service reminds
me of my childhood
where's that trail mix
um joanna
when i say i love
and admire you
like i truly mean it
it's hard to put into words
when you've like been alongside of
someone
you know and you're just
you've made me feel so much safer in the
world
you've inspired me
you've made me feel like i can realize
my dreams because as women watching you
grow
and i don't think very genderline-ish
like i think i'm probably just as much
like chip as i am like you i'm
androgynous
but to see a working mom
build the way that you've done and it
has just been so beautiful watching your
journey as a consumer then i'm sure i
speak for
you know gazillions of people let alone
women out there thank you for saying
that and if there's any way that this
can connect with women and hopefully
empower and inspire them i mean that's
the greatest honor that's the greatest
gift joe
this has been so fun
[Music]
you